the restored Colonial Village of Williamsburg
Virginia even in the earliest days of our nation
the druggists mortar and pestle was a proud
symbol of reliability but how reliable where
the concoctions assembled by the pharmacist to
that area from a weird collection of herbs roots
and other medications whose use was dictated
more by tradition than sound authority how pure
uniform and stable were they and how much
laborious work went into their preparation
the conscientious apothecary of days gone by
did his best to fill the doctor's prescription
to the letter but he had no control over the
deterioration of his chemicals no proper way
of blending them no means for testing their
strength it's little wonder that on some
occasions the remedy did more damage than the
ailment it was intended to cure wonderful to
look back into the past like this but as so
often happens we find on closer inspection
that the good old days weren't quite as good as we
imagine today for example the pharmacist commands
the resources of America's great drug industry
for example firms like Rexall drug company in
whose Los Angeles laboratories we find scientists
constantly improving on old established products
and constantly seeking new practical uses for
the discoveries of the research scientists
samples produced in the laboratories pilot plant
are stored for long periods under all sorts of
temperatures and humidity then are analyzed
to determine if any change has taken place
the mortar and pestle are still in
use in this case tablets are ground
up before going through any number of analyses
first the samples are weighed on an
analytical balance scales so sensitive
they can tell the weight of an eyelash
or your signature on a piece of paper
they have the most uncanny ways of determining
the exact chemical and physical makeup of a
drug for example if they want to find the
amount of vitamin b12 it contains they add
microorganisms that require that vitamin for
growth as the bugs developed they cause the
liquid to become cloudy when all the vitamin
is consumed the microorganism stops growing and
the degree of cloudiness reveals the potency
of the vitamin various elements are known to
absorb a precise amount of infrared light rays
so they passed such rays through a sample and
the rays that are not absorbed are recorded on a
graph revealing exactly the nature of the sample
we take our drugstores pretty much for
granted but to many of the residents
of 17th century Williamsburg a store like
this when it spells the difference between
life and death come to think of it
I guess it smells the same to us